bueno
[Aplausos]
[Música]
primero agradecer a la organización por
invitarme a participar esta noche
en esta edición del ex um y 2019
y
no hay evolución sin reinvención
que es primero
evolucionar para reinventarse o
reinventarse para evolucionar
desde mi humilde experiencia quiero
[Música]
y decirles que hace
algún tiempo atrás hace 10 años
aproximadamente no me imaginaba poder
estar parada de esta forma conversando
con un grupo considerado de personas y
hablando de esta manera de esta forma me
refiero a estas respondas y mis facetas
como actriz o cantante
así recuerdo la primera vez que me
contrataron como maestra de ceremonias y
la verdad es que fue una experiencia
terrible me sudaban las manos olvidado
mis líneas no hilaba frases
una experiencia atroz para mí
deseamos tener la soltura tener la
tranquilidad de poder hablar con un
grupo de gente sin miedos internos
admiraban los grandes conferencistas que
podían mover corazones y dejar un
mensaje con aplomo y con seguridad
entonces hace nueve años tomé una
decisión importante en mi vida y decidí
hacer un alto
[Música]
en la música popular
para iniciar una búsqueda la búsqueda de
algo que yo sentía que me faltaba
hice algo me llevo
a encontrarme conmigo misma
pero también llegó a cometer muchos
errores
buscaba la aceptación y la aprobación
de los demás también buscaba ser amada
y cayó muy profundo
transite por estados de depresión
desesperación desesperanza
miedos
culpas
felizmente en el 2014 apareció el hada
madrina
con ayuda profesional descubrí que desde
muy niña me acompañaba una herramienta
de autoayuda
que te ayudarán a analizar todo lo que
pensaban y sentían solo que hasta ese
momento no le había prestado la debida
importancia
esta herramienta también me ayudaba a
volcar
todo mi ser cuando venían una serie de
imágenes a mi cabeza es simplemente lo
dejamos fluir
sin darme cuenta
todo lo que declaraban
estaba llena de piezas y lamentos
en ese momento
analizaba que me criticaba fuertemente
y me culpaba por todos los errores que
cometí mientras me hacía adulta
pero que podría ser esta herramienta tan
sencilla y poderosa a la vez
nada más fácil que agarrar una hoja de
papel y un lapicero y ponerse a escribir
pero me busque ahí van más allá era más
profunda
así que decidí investigar leer acudir a
seminarios acudir a charlas de
crecimiento personal y desarrollo
escuchar conferencias y participar de
muchos webinars online sobre el
liderazgo
escuchaba las grandes conferencistas
hablar acerca de él
evolución del ser reinvención saltos
cuánticos ir más allá el poder interior
la voz interna y el propósito de vida
así que en el 2014
hago un alto en el camino también y me
vuelvo más aguda y analítica con lo que
escribía y dice momento decido de romper
desarmar
desordenar
todo mi interior todo lo que veía
pensando y siendo hasta ese momento
y toma la decisión de reconstruir
reordenar todo desde cero y recuperar
esa fe y esa confianza que aún me hacía
falta
porque tampoco valoraba mis talentos y
todo lo que había conseguido a lo largo
de mi camino artístico con esfuerzo
así que me regreso a cero porque eso fue
por ella los ángeles
[Música]
a mi regreso al perú decidió tomar un
diplomado en la universidad
y estando allí
tomó también la decisión de seguir con
él
con la carrera profesional de coaching
ontológico
[Música]
la cual me ha enseñado habilidades y
competencias
que ha venido aplicando en mi vida que
me hacían falta y empoderando algunas
que tenían mismos días
en estas prácticas conversacionales
aparecían por mi mente muchas preguntas
esas preguntas movilizadoras esas
preguntas que no te dejan tranquilo como
maricela que hiciste antes marisela
donde estuviste marisela porque no te
diste cuenta o que veloz tenias frente a
ti y precisamente ese era el momento del
despertando mi conciencia plena de lo
que pensaba declaraba y hacía
paulatinamente me fui alejando de todo
todo lo que yo consideraba tóxico
emocional
personas situaciones relaciones
programas de televisión noticias y
comida chatarra
aunque no lo creemos también había
decidido ser una chica fija por lo tanto
cada vez que yo quería comer algo rico
fuera de mi régimen era esa ese
conflicto interno entre lo que no debía
hacer y lo que quería hacer así que no
era para nada saludable
[Música]
vamos a tomar este ejemplo
en este camino
[Música]
del cual yo decido continuar
también aparecían preguntas sobre
vivimos en un mundo tan rápido vivimos
en un mundo veloz donde aparecen y
surgen nuevas ciudades se fusionan
culturas
aparecen nuevas formas de vida y si no
me monto en la ola de lo nuevo que
sucede qué pasa si no me monto en la ola
hoy con todo lo nuevo y con todo lo que
conllevan los cambios tal vez nos pase
como le sucedió al buscar personas
llamado miller creado en 1940
popularizado en los 80 y luego
reemplazado por los smartphones
y hace 70 años atrás casi nadie se
imaginaba que luego podríamos estar
conversando por videocámara como lo
hacemos hoy simplificando nos nuestra
vida
y en este momento de la charla me surgen
preguntas como
sin subir donde quiera estar
y que estoy haciendo para mejorar lo que
soy yo y para más adelante
y
muchas veces limitamos nuestra
inteligencia a lo ya aprendido
al saberlo todo
[Música]
ya lo sé siempre me zona de confort
me siento en la comodidad del control
pero qué pasa si decidió romper esta
zona de confort y salir adelante en
búsqueda de lo que yo quiero
estaré conectándome con el camino de la
evolución
y cuando te conectas con ese camino
aparece el propósito de vida
en la reinvención está la evolución
proponernos nuevos retos nuevas metas
nos mantendrán siempre aprender nuevas
carreras fusionar nuestra carrera con
otras
salir al mundo y conocer nuevas culturas
aprender nuevos idiomas nos mantendrá
siempre vigentes
[Música]
en este momento quiero hacer
un ejercicio de 30 segundos con ustedes
vamos a soltar las manos a los costados
soltemos las manos
inhalamos exhalamos y cerramos los ojos
[Música]
y salud
y cierre los ojos
estando ahí
vamos a trasladarnos al 2014 en
noviembre del 2014
recuerda dónde estabas con quién estabas
qué hacías y cómo te sentías
siguen respirando
y sanando
vamos a dar una última
y migración instalación
recordando lo que transitaron por
nuestro ser en esa época
y abrimos los ojos lentamente
qué pasó
[Música]
que levante la mano
los valientes que siguen siendo
el mismo se hace cinco años atrás
con las mismas costumbres los mismos
hábitos
las últimas ilusiones
cambiar
un poquito
cómo me siento en relación a hace cinco
años atrás
el reto está
y adaptarse
aprender a crear posibilidades adquirir
amigas
nelson mandela fue abogado y defensor de
los derechos de la raza negra en su país
fue víctima de una emboscada política y
encerrado 27 años en la cárcel y lejos
de mantenerse con rencor y lamentarse
decidió reinventarse con lo único que él
tenía se tenía a él sus talentos y sus
ganas de querer salir de ahí siendo
mejor
cuenta la historia que cada noche se
repetía un poema del cual me sacaba un
fragmento
más allá de la noche que me cubre negra
como el abismo insondable doy gracias a
los dioses que pudieran existir por mi
alma y mitad
en 1990
soy liberal
y cuatro años más tarde fue declarado
presidente y fue el presidente que marcó
la historia en sudáfrica
no permitamos que nuestros miedos
nos limite en alcanzar lo que queremos
no permitamos que nuestra voz militante
y limitante nos deje en el mismo lugar
visualicemos
pero seamos constantes marquemos una
disciplina vivamos en el hoy disfrutemos
el hoy
pero siempre con un ojo en el futuro
el secreto de la evolución está en la
constante transformación del ser
y ciertamente la tecnología nos ayuda a
avanzar y nos brinda la información que
necesitamos para lograr nuestros
proyectos y nuestros objetivos pero como
dice andrés oppenheimer en su entrega
sálvese quien pueda la tecnología está
avanzando a ritmos acelerados
vertiginosamente y está a su paso
destruyendo millones de empleos sin que
estos puedan ser reemplazados por otros
y cuántos de nosotros quisiéramos tener
un robot que nos asista en el trabajo en
la casa
y cuando esto suceda masivamente porque
ya está sucediendo nos parece de américa
cuando se sigan sigan
[Música]
millán los profesionales serán
desplazados para hablar gramática a la
automatización
señoras y señores
es nuestra vocación reventadas
personal y profesional
y antes de desear quiero dejarles pasar
así
la habitación del hotel
[Música]
está bastante claro avanzar
profundo de acero de transformación y
superación en todas las áreas de tu vida
personal profesional intelectual
espiritual
bastaron activación diagnóstica y
extremista dentro y fuera toda la acción
porque si tenemos todos los
conocimientos a la brasa es el primer
paso nada de nada
y luego nos conectaremos vamos a hacer
en ambición
y para realizarlas
vidal desde la conciencia plena de que
declaramos deseamos pensamos ustedes
desde la realidad ser agradecidos con el
universo por latina su vida
no permitas que la mañana
en su interior muchas gracias
[Aplausos]